what are your thoughts on vaping
come on well I'm smoking a cigar right
now but I know what a cigar is cigars
tobacco you've been around for a very
long time I I did my high school a
little bit yeah I did I Vaped I Vaped
I'll sneak on the chat forever yep yeah
thank you for sending the chat up to
come and call me gecko again you go down
a little bit yeah I know it has nicotine
in it I know the good another bad Etc
the reason I am anti-vaping is because
nobody knows he's even in a [__]
and it's produced so cheaply somewhere
in the Far East by people who don't give
a single solitary [__] about human
rights of their own people let alone the
people of the West for pennies please
explain to me what chemical combination
contagious you don't know nobody will
know Plastics bro what chemicals need to
be put together to taste like pineapple
ice
nobody knows wait what can I say can I
say one thing though you do hookah and
it's flavored yeah it's flavored tobacco
with fruit fruit on Tobacco it's natural
what's actually what's no what scares me
what scares me about Vape is how
accurate the flavors are right please
understand the point how much they
target kids with that [__] like the
whole Market is literally for children
with the flavors like [__] blue
Raspberry Vanilla like all the random
stuff it's directly marketed there's a
team of dudes in a room who's like we
are gonna make a bunch of money off of
getting kids addicted to these like that
was a legit discussion vanilla
strawberry fruity fruit cake it's wild
five from not a Jewish lawyer so if the
job is harder it's soul-crushing
unfortunately you also had an entire
platform through batsu before you
started streaming it's difficult to
start I've been watching you since the
Cod days all up Cod days that was a
decade ago not a Jewish lawyer everyone
Call of Duty that's when I was uh like
that's back when I was a teenager that's
it's insane
um yeah it could be Soul question like
when they remove all of your work and
stuff like that I've genuinely learned a
lot
um in this consecration world uh but you
know it's a new industry so I don't
think Andrew fully understands it or but
well it's probably just easier than the
stuff he did you know like kickboxing or
oh it's not even yeah it's so much
easier like that I mean we'll be real
about that no I think streaming is
pretty equal to kickboxing
bro the BFF pod that that girl did you
see that where she she told Tate that
he's basically like a dancer
because he did kickboxing like
unironically this is a podcast people
listen to She said kickboxing is the
equivalent of being a dancer
but the training is actually
um
oh my God you remember I showed you the
video of Tate Dancing Yeah that wasn't
actually tape oh it wasn't you thought
that was him dude we started filming and
I showed it to her as a joke and she
believed it so I just went with it yeah
I you didn't know till now come on I was
so impressed why is dude he was like
shaking yeah I thought he looks a little
he looked a little like he looked a
little drag queenish in it but I so I I
did I think I said something at the time
like I'm not sure about his moves but
like wow I was so impressed that he
could dance oh damn you fooled me can I
ask you a Gen X question yeah that um I
apologize Sonny before I asked the
question
um did you ever hear Sean Connery talk
about like slapping your wife
no tell me Well he said that like if
your wife acts out of line like it's a
good just one slap
sounds like some [__] he would have said
yeah no he actually said that in an
interview
yeah I I don't know Dad no very very
very bad yeah well you know I don't know
if you ever saw any of the videos where
Sunny interviews my mom and uh Grace
grandma she was tough as nails and she
wasn't taking anybody's crap so
um my father when they first got married
yeah tough Grandma she's a beast she's
watching right now oh yeah hey shout out
Grandma shout out
um when they first got married they got
into a fight and he struck her and she
picked up do you remember those old uh
those old heavy phones they sat on the
desk they were like metal and you know
yeah and she picked up that phone and
she beat the [__] out of him and he went
to work the next day like black eye like
Cuts oh [__] your grandma beat the
grandma because he hit he went he's got
a grandma you met you he hit her and she
was like I am not living like this and
she beat the [__] out of him and that
was to the you know as the story is told
the last time anybody ever laid their
hands on each other
my grandpa's a g I don't know what was
going on no he was a g he was a real
dude but he he but his wife he grew up
in an abusive household so he he was
used to it and she was like this ain't
happening like I'll kill you before I
live in a house where I get hit so uh
that's how I was raised I was raised
with that being told that story as a
little kid so Sean Connery ever came up
and slapped me Sean Connery he'd have a
he'd have a handful on his hands what do
you think of that because like the way I
look at it is like would you want
someone to hit your mom and if the
answer is no it's like then I feel like
it should be a no yeah you shouldn't
even have to go that far to ask the
questions it's just no
just know hands to yourself fly from a
mirror yo bro you got to properly
humidify your cigars man you can't get
the cheap ones online it's really
important so they don't try out mold
much love is going to work hard to make
it out the Matrix okay bro
um you cigar watching like crazy when it
says pineapple ice and you taste it
you're like wow it does taste like
pineapple like blueberry mango smoothie
yeah or [__] Cherry Bomb you taste it
you're like it tastes exactly like it's
supposed to yeah wait how the [__] do
you make chemicals tastes like Cherry
Bomb wait this costs 79 cents there's
something in there [__] Indonesia
yeah this cannot they have not
considered how this damages my body to
make it taste like this so Andrew I gave
my friend ten thousand dollars to stop
smoking for a month this is a true story
I swear one of my closest friends and I
looked at this as spitting in my face
I'm gonna say the story give me ten
thousand dollars stop smoke for a month
31 days goes by 30 second day he smokes
it looks like spitting in my face I paid
the ten thousand I'm a man where I stuck
to it spam my face though what do you
think about that well that was the deal
that's the deal you made
so but what was he vaping yeah I just
wanted to help him because I vaping is a
crippling addiction let me tell you
something about helping people you can't
help anyone else want to help himself
true so this is another very key did you
ever try to get like Hometown friends
and stuff like that into
entrepreneurship and making content yeah
and it never worked did it failed I
would say oh I need help no they don't
it's crazy they they want to try and
externalize all of the willpower because
they have none of it themselves here we
go I lack motivation if you want to quit
you quit right yeah you can't help
people who don't want to help themselves
people say this kind of [__] all the
time like this motivation oh I don't
have motivation to go to the gym if you
don't have motivation to go and be
strong then stay weak and [__] off like
what do you want me to do it's true like
so you can't you can there's an age-old
adage you can take you can drag a horse
to the water but you can't fix it it's
true yeah it's 100 true people I really
believe the universe is ultimately
giving I've never seen anybody or any
experience in my life where somebody has
dedicated their all and tried their very
best for something and not happy do you
agree thousand percent
being [__] ing [__] cracking the
first shot I'd rather riding on the wall
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]